herr trittin ich möchte darüber sprechen
was in den kommenden jahren in einer
möglichen neuen ampel regierung beim
thema klimaschutz passieren könnte und
möchte erst einmal darauf zu sprechen
kommen die umweltaktivisten von freitags
fünf user
demonstriert haben den reicht das
nämlich gar nicht aus was die ampel dazu
bislang sondiert sie haben protestiert
hätten wie haben sie das empfunden
das ist in ordnung ich finde das richtig
dass an dieser stelle
demonstriert wird das eindruck gemacht
wird weil ich schon denke es wird eine
herkulesaufgabe sein dieses land auf den
1,5 grad fahrt zu bringen aber es gibt
ein paar dinge über die muss man sich im
klaren sein wenn man auch diesen 1,5
grad fahrt kommen will dann wird man in
den nächsten
zehn jahren
zum beispiel photovoltaik und
windenergie anlagen ans netz bringen
müssen in einer größenordnung von 300
gigawattstunden pro jahr
das ist genauso viel wie wir in den
letzten 20 jahren installiert haben
daran wird sich entscheiden ob es uns
zum beispiel gelingt operation vom
radweg sie die abhängigkeit und fossilen
energien und die abhängigkeit von
menschen zb in ihrem wärmebedarf von den
gaspreisen zu reduzieren es gibt die
herausforderung es gibt den vorwurf
gegen sie oder gegen ihre partei dass
sie für ein paar regierungs jobs das
klima gefährden oder am ende die
situation weiterhin schlimm bleibt was
sagen sie zu dem vorwurf sehe das sehr
gelassen ist nochmal ich bleibe bei der
feststellung wir müssen diese blockade
beim ausbau erneuerbarer energien das
fängt an bei der 10h regelung in bayern
und das geht weiter bei der bestrafung
von menschen die gemeinsam mit anderen
auf ihrem dach strom erzeugen wollen um
damit zum beispiel eine elektrische
wärmepumpe zu betreiben damit sie nicht
mehr das kaufen müssen dies alles muss
weg geräumt werden und nur dann werden
wir eine chance haben und ich streite
nicht gerne darüber welche ziele in
welchem zeitraum erreicht werden können
aber wenn diese voraussetzung nicht
geschaffen worden ist dann wenn
überhaupt gar kein ziel erreicht haben
sie denn ernsthaft dass sie mit fdp und
spd diesen kurs 1,5 grad ziel ernsthaft
erreichen können
die beiden koalitionspartner haben das
schön so regierungspakt dem papier so
gemeinsam mit uns vereinbart und ich
habe überhaupt keinen anlass daran zu
zweifeln dass das was sie aufgeschrieben
haben von ihnen ernst gemeint ist
herrscher wenn sich das anschauen wieder
verhandelt wird glauben sie dass die
regierung am ende das 1,5 grad ziel
erreicht und wir leben ja gerade dass es
eine debatte darüber gibt ob man nicht
auch beim thema kernkraftwerke nach
steuern müsste was eine verlängerung
angeht der laufzeiten wie stehen sie
dazu
also punkt 1
herr trittin weiß ja es ist relativ
schlau
windkraftanlage dorthin zu stellen wo
wirklich gut wind
vorkommt und
dieses argumenten immer dieser schlenker
nach bayern dafür sind wir sonnen
bundeslandes in dem dass wir die sonne
nutzen und in anderen bereichen ist
sicherlich die windkraft
besser geeignet zweitens dann hoffe ich
dass die grünen vor ort ihre ganzen
proteste gingen leitungsbau aufgeben
denn der behindert uns massiv ist
ähnlich wie bei den großen bahn trassen
am rednerpult im deutschen bundestag ist
noch immer für gutes schienennetz und
hochleistungs strecken wenn man dann
stichwort bielefeld hannover vor ort
kommt oder firma beltquerung dann ist
man dagegen ist bei der energie genau
dasselbe gelassen glaube ich ist er
tritt ihn definitiv nicht weil er weiß
um die herkulesaufgabe die uns alle
angeht die wir alle erreichen wollen ich
halte jetzt nichts davon nachzusteuern
bei anderen energieformen sondern wir
müssen mit unserer innovation aber mit
einer besseren
umsetzungsgeschwindigkeit es hinbekommen
die regenerativen auszubauen aber
nochmal genau das ist ja momentan
problem
elektroauto wasserstoff lkw regenerative
energien dieses zeitliche delta der
umsetzung haben wir momentan und dies
müssen wir mit kraftvollen politischen
entscheidungen jetzt über brücken um
auch den leuten entgegen zu kommen um
auch die akzeptanz zu erhöhen um dann
eben einen umgebauten energiesektor zu
haben aber auch einen umgebauten
mobilitätssektor zu haben um dort mit
alternativen antrieben mit regenerativen
energien mit synthetischen kraftstoffen
auch unabhängiger zu werden von den
importen und von daher das müsste die
strategie sein jetzt bin ich kein
ratgeber für die opel-verhandlungen aber
ich denke gelassen sein kann man nicht
ist es jetzt relativ
ruhig und diszipliniert was die
ampelkoalition ehre hier verhandeln das
haben wir bei jamaika leider wo wir
beteiligt waren anders gesehen in der
letzten periode leider das war ein
riesenfehler und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was das ergebnis ist ist
sondierungs papier ist er eine
beruhigungspille für die parteigremien
gewesen entscheiden wird was im
koalitionspapier drin steht
[Musik]